guten brauch jetzt weil mir erstmal
gucken ist ja nur im internet ich sags
ja nur ich werde in diesem video zeigen
wie cdu leute lügen wie sie sich
augenscheinlich an verschiedenen
kriegsverbrechen beteiligen wie sie
propaganda und unwahrheiten gegen die
junge generation einsetzen ich finde
kinder ist aber okay merkel hat jetzt
angekündigt dass sie zehn prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes für bildung und
forschung ausgeben will
da haben sie recht bitte hat sie sich
gar nicht dran gehalten nicht mal die
hälfte
nein ja also ich bin erst mal jemand der
sehr stark dafür ist dass wir die umwelt
abbauen also wir haben ja viel geschafft
warum jemand richtig gut wirtschaften
und zum leben brauche ich ganz vieles
aber vor allen dingen und das ist das
wichtigste
eine funktionierende er gut leben heißt
erst einmal so richtig mal alles
rauszulassen was sozusagen in mir an
negativen gefühlen ist wie sie sind
jetzt mit der cdu aus also die sind doch
bestimmt kompetenter und würden doch
nicht so klare wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse unten überwältigenden
konsens über notwendiges verhalten
einfach ignorieren
ja irgendwie okay also das klingt schon
mal so als hätte dieses thema für jeden
politiker unfassbar hohe priorität dann
kommt doch alles schaffen wie können so
stand super packen und die cdu der spd
sie müssen eigentlich nur das umsetzen
was die wissenschaftler sagen ist doch
lies es gibt ja menschen die sagen und
da umwelt schützen niveau in europa ist
nicht hoch genug und die würden gerne
auch das was wir in europa als schutz
haben noch mal ein bisschen anheben das
machen wir jetzt nicht was ding ist beim
aktuellen kurs ist in unter neun jahren
diese menge aufgebracht aber merkel
möchte bis 2038 noch kohlekraft anlassen
geht ja nur um unsere fucking zukunft
ist es besteht keine absicht dass auch
die jüngeren gut leben in deutschland ja
okay also spd und cdu halten die
kohlekraft irgendwie künstlich am leben
was irgendwie kein was bringt außer halt
den park ohne druck weil die cdu halt
viel steuergeldern dahin gibt und die
auch mal gerne was zurückgeben an die
cdu
glaube ich freuen wir uns aber auch
nicht politisch zu sagen ja mache ich
das natürlich in meiner politischen
arbeit auch der krieg geht es mir jetzt
nicht um so sachen wie das sich merkel
zb anfangen für den irak krieg
ausgesprochen hat dieser krieg ist eine
realität und ich unterstütze die
vereinigten staaten von amerika und
heutzutage scheint ihr das peinlich zu
sein und sie läutet das halt ich
unterstütze nie einen krieg ich habe
auch den irak krieg nicht unterstützt
und da fliegen die halt echt gern diese
kampfdrohnen die können die noch nicht
von zu hause aus steuern
weil das halt auf der anderen seite der
welt ist und wegen der erdkrümmung geht
das nicht die cdu und die spd sagen amys
macht das doch gerne hier von rammstein
aus mainz stellt euch mal vor europa ist
ein garten und die buddelt da so die
möhren aus die sie gesät hat vor ein
paar monaten und plötzlich ist sie weg
stellt euch mal vor das wär ein auto
oder sind so eure eltern oder kinder
drin
ob sie daisy diese tötung wurden über
ramstein über unser land gesteuert
stelle mal vor irgendein land kommt an
und zerfetzt vor deinen augen deine
kinder oder deine frau natürlich hast du
hast in deinem herzen und den wunsch
nach rache wenn man es mal anguckt das
seitdem dieser krieg gegen den terror
angefangen hat der terrorismus zunimmt
dann schaut doch so aus wenigstens kann
ich wenn wir in ein paar jahrzehnten
diese erde für alle kommenden
generationen geschickt haben in den
spiegel schauen und sagen ich habe
aufrichtig nach logik nach
wissenschaftlichen konsens und nach
christlichen und humanistischen werten
gehandelt und ich hoffe ihr könnt das
auch von euch behaupten gerade an der
grund stelle ist man tatsächlich die
lust nach winzigen schnitt vergangen als
ich das video gearbeitet habe deswegen
ist ja das ende das war natürlich keine
persönliche beleidigung eine frau merkel
sei nur eine art moderne satire und
jetzt guckt euch auf jeden fall weil sie
noch nicht gesehen habe dass ihm hier an
lodsys ganz anzugucken und die robe bald
natürlich auch die entdecker haben
sonntag mehr möchte ich auch gar nicht
sagen dass wir an alle fans natürlich
auch verlinkt und wenn ich auf dieser
reise begleiten möchte der abonniert
diesen kanal
[Musik]